in the name of jesus from south america
they're coming here
they're coming here they're coming here
they're coming here
from africa
i hear the sound of victory
[Music]
i hear the sound of victory i hear the
sound of victory
i hear the sound of winning winning
winning
winning winning
should i play this this is one of the
most vile callers we have
take a listen to the i have not
pre-screened this so i let me just warn
you
this may not be suitable for children
for children
hey little prickles now that your uh
your
hero is there are you going to sit there
in your little kimono
and wear your little hat rice
because it's going to be called no free
speech
red chinese communist speech
but you can't have pork because you
might offend the ayatollahs
after all they're going to love this too
they're going to make a bomb and i hope
they drop it right on your freaking ass
but you can't have pork but you can't
have pork
you can't have pork you like to stick
that microphone right up your ass
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
which to any experienced investigator
prosecutor would suggest that there was
a
a plan from a centralized place
to execute these various acts of voter
fraud
specifically focused on big cities
and specifically focused on as you would
imagine
big cities controlled by david
[Music]
the system is totally rigged
[Music]
and i'm sure he's listening because he
watches every word and i guarantee you
one thing
he's watching us like he never watched
anybody before
one of the most serious challenges our
countries face
is the specter of david
the wrecker of nations and destroyers of
[Music]
societies
all right wow what an introduction i am
completely undeserving of it i can tell
you that for sure
we are here because we are just minutes
from very powerful testimony now
i already have to explain but by
testimony do i mean anything that is
legally
uh valid will rudy giuliani be
under oath i don't believe so so the
term testimony is
quite loose i'm using the term loosely
we will see if he is actually sworn in
but we are standing by for rudy giuliani
and i think it is going to be absolutely
bananas
and i have so many things to play for
you guys today
i have new songs i have emails i have a
hilarious
only fans call that we took today
i have uh what else do i have i always
come prepared
for people we may even open the phone
lines depending on how things go
jake asked via super chat whether i saw
trump's address to the nation and that
it was demented
it was completely crazy i have a couple
of clips of it
um we can just look at one check this
out
um this is this is like it's completely
insane hold on let me get the right
thing going for you here yeah listen
listen to this this election was rigged
everybody knows it i don't mind if i
lose an election
but i want to lose an election fair and
square
what i don't want to do is have it
stolen from the american people
that's what we're fighting for and we
have no choice to be
doing that by the way what's with this
camera angle we already have the proof
we already have the evidence
and it's very clear many people in the
media
and even judges so far have refused to
accept it it's so funny like
everything's projection it's
the only person refusing to accept
anything
are trump and his supporters the media
has even fox news during the day
has accepted that joe biden won judges
look at
the evidence and they say there's no
merit to this
uh it's all just total projection and
listen this is good trump takes out a
chart this is really wild
that wisconsin
we're leading by a lot and then
at 3 42 in the morning
there was this it was a massive dump
oh god i have a lot of massive dump
content for you guys
um the so i'm going to cover this more
extensively tomorrow
but the funny thing about the 3 42 am is
remember on election night pennsylvania
stopped counting
i don't remember we were all here i
don't remember if it was 10 p.m or 11
p.m
and the right wingers were going crazy
saying
they're stopping the count in the middle
of an election
that's suspicious dave rubin
said they i guess they needed naps i
don't know why they stopped counting so
the fact that they stopped counting in
pennsylvania was evidence of some kind
of
something bad here trump is saying
3 42 in the morning that's a weird ass
time to be counting votes wait a second
so
you've criticized both that they stopped
counting votes
and didn't go into the night in some
states that was evidence of
fraud in some states and here the
evidence of fraud is 3 42 in the morning
the the cover of night is the idea so
it's called an indefeasible argument
because you can't well i'm spitting up
all over myself i'm so fired up
either way it's part of the conspiracy
and this is often how conspiracy
theorists work so anyway
i'm not going to keep going on that but
yes trump addressed the nation
um and then one other thing i had for
you
was kaylee morgannani saying
that it's the trump vaccine where is
this yeah listen to this we will have 40
million doses by the end of the year
which is a
tremendous achievement not just to have
gotten a vaccine in this time
but to have produced 40 million in
advance it's having a businessman as
president the trump vaccine the trump
vaccine and what's funny is of course
the
the reason that the vaccines were
developed so quickly which i'm glad i'm
so happy about i mean it's fantastic
the mrna mrna platform
which does not inject uh a piece of
virus but it's a
essentially injecting instructions it's
a very powerful injection of
instructions
as to how to deal with the virus would
the body
and count encounter it it just takes
less time to
develop so vaccines that were part of
operation warp speed
and the ones that weren't and vaccines
in other countries
they all were developed on the exact
same timeline and
all are likely to be approved within
weeks of each other trump was
operation warp speed was involved in
some of them and not in others that's
why the vaccine was developed quickly it
has nothing to do with trump
it's just a faster uh process when
you're using the mrna platform we've
talked about it already
okay that's it um all right what else do
we have
um aline is asking about the boner show
yeah okay so let me get to that next i
did have a freudian slip the other day
and we kept it in the show because i
thought it was so funny
check this out this is what happened
let's remind you
that we have a tremendous bonus bonus
show
oh boy so i mean listen we could we
could have edited it out
edited it out um
but it's just funny so we kept it um so
that's it the the boner show was it was
a pretty strong show i'm not gonna lie
um so that's that aline checking in
about that
um what else oh
dr chakaseki radiologist says i think
kaylie's next official step is to create
a paper smoke screen
by tossing files and files of paper in
the air
to create a factual tornado yes well
said well said her props are much needed
syed ahmad says you're my favorite
plasma boy
keep up the good work oliver says since
trump is trading pardons for money i'm
curious can pardons be overturned or
repealed after they've been granted
we have no evidence trump is trading
pardons for money the investigation
claims that there are people accepting
money to go
lobby trump for pardons but we don't
want to say more than than we actually
are aware of
i want to say a huge thank you to jane
leclaire
who is new member number one today at
joinpackman.com
uh if we get to 100 we will be opening
the phone lines
uh i got an only fan's phone call today
do you guys want to hear it i might be
willing to uh
to play it uh let me see where we are
from the standpoint of twitch
one two three subs on twitch which puts
us at four
this is pretty funny um i'll play this
for you guys this will air on the friday
show take a listen to this
hold on a second oh hold on oh god that
went completely wrong let me actually
get that
i think you guys are going to like this
uh
i actually i i couldn't stop laughing
myself because this was so funny
hey david it's me um i just was
wondering if you've ever reconsidered
making an only benz
sorry if i if i've done making an
omelette what no no making it only fans
uh you know
uh gardening season is over and it's
time for you to show us your zucchini
that's very clever no listen um i think
i'd i'd be more likely
uh i'd be more likely to show my my
granny smith apples
than any zooks to be perfectly frank
flippy
that works too yeah uh no but i am on
cameo which i think is like the work
safe
only fans right well that works
well thank you and by the way where does
the name flippy come from
oh just an alias online oh does it have
any meaning
no does it relate to like a floppy disk
for example remember those five and a
quarter inches
oh it's supposed to be like flippy
floppy like a stupid way to call
flip-flops
oh i got it by the way are you cleaning
a violin in the background
i know it's birds sorry oh it's a bird
oh okay i think this may be the funniest
phone call that we've we've ever
received
i i was i i mentioned it
afterwards to a few people and i could
not uh
let's just listen to it once more just a
bit of it i just was wondering if you've
ever reconsidered making an only fans
sorry if i if i've done making an
omelette what no no making it only fans
you know uh gardening season is over and
it's time for you to show us your
zucchini
that's very clever no listen um i think
i'd i'd be more likely
uh i'd be more likely to show my my
granny smith apples
all right so really really funny phone
call that'll air on
the friday podcast if you are not what
is this
if you are not yet getting the audio
podcast you really should
it is a very very good time
okay continuing on here other super
chats coming in
johnny minogue wonders if we'll hear
from melissa carone
and all of her flat vowels no i think
she
oh wait this isn't she's from michigan
right this is this is michigan maybe we
will
um bay photo wants to know if the boner
show is sponsored by
fakheiser not yet ali kitkat says flynn
is advocating martial law is that
possible yeah he's out of his mind
completely out of his mind
and m asks what's so suspicious about
ballots arriving at 4 00 a.m
in my country ballots arrive at the
count for hours after the election ends
yeah it's weird it's like if you stop
counting they get mad and if you keep
counting they say
4 a.m is a really weird time to be
counting it's like either way it's
strange to them very very strange um and
then lastly i got a very funny email
about the everybody's using massive
dumps now check out this email i got
massive value with the new coupon hi
david long time viewer finally signed up
i was surprised at the huge massive dump
of value
the coupon code fresh start gave me i
hope
everybody understands you're dropping
massive dumps of savings all over the
place
thank you and keep up the work the good
work bryce that's a great message from
bryce
and i don't know how many of you have
heard this before but we do have a
really strong
massive dumps song parody now this is
really strong
i was called by the biggest dumps they
call them dumps
big massive dumps
[Music]
top song
[Music]
here we go big massive dumps
[Applause]
it's very well done
big massive dump
[Music]
big massive dumpster
[Music]
anyway you guys get the idea so that's a
really strong song and i hope
uh to be able to bring to bring more of
it there's actually a lot of uh
there's a lot of other songs we got like
here's just one other one
the biggest we've ever seen big massive
dump
coming in rapidly massive dumps
big massive dump huge new
dumpster coming in rapidly
[Music]
so we got that one that's from rusty
lewis physic
dj physics and then they did dumps they
call them dumps
big massive dumps in michigan
so they're coming in from all over it's
non-stop in fact these just will not
stop being sent to us which is great
really creative stuff coming in from the
audience
if you're just joining us we are
standing by from what we are expecting
to be
comedically valuable and mimetic
testimony
from rudy giuliani something about fraud
freud or fraud we are expecting to hear
any moment now absolutely any moment uh
i do want to say thank you to justine
atwood who is new member number five
today at joinpacman.com and also
a big thank you to jimmy 10 pins as well
as
darth bane for the twitch subs which
puts us at seven
uh if we get to a hundred i will open
the phone lines and i would love to hear
from you guys and we will get to that a
little bit later
a bunch of people asking whether i saw
the trump video earlier i did
we played one clip from it earlier on
stream
and i will do a full uh breakdown
tomorrow of that
so we've got that covered and then what
else did i have for you guys
i always come prepared i guess we've
gotten through a lot of material already
um oh i have a couple other things but
i'll save them
in case we need them a little later uh
okay people recommending various
political parody songs and things like
that always very very much
appreciated oh uh oh oh oh this i wanted
to mention this
all right tomorrow night this is
non-political this is a break from
politics
tomorrow night 8 p.m eastern
i am running a chess tournament friendly
tournament
anybody can play i'm co-hosting it with
international chess master
levy rosman who streams really strongly
under the name gotham chess grand master
benjamin feingold will be playing we
have some other potential
large names who will be playing
anybody can play okay davidpakman.com
chess will uh direct you to our chess
club on chess.com
and then tomorrow within an hour of the
start you'll be invited to the actual
tournament okay davidpakman.com
chess no raiding cap no raiding
floor everybody's welcome everybody's
welcome we're going to be dumping
massive amounts of chess uh tomorrow
night
okay so davidpakman.com
chess i hope to see all of you it'll be
a 90-minute tournament tomorrow night 8
p.m eastern
5 p.m pacific really really it's going
to be a great thing just a break from
the politics that's all it is if you
don't like it if you want only politics
you don't have to play we're just it's
building community
levy rosman and i will be uh we'll be
streaming
i believe we've invited eric rosen levy
was supposed to invite eric rosen
and that'll be tomorrow okay
davidpakman.com
chess okay um what else do we have
going on from the standpoint of the show
any end of year break yeah we'll be here
we're we're here
so that the we're here every day weekday
until the last week of the year so the
week of december 28th
we're taking that entire week off and
that'll include sort of like the
the christmas uh weekend and then the
new year's weekend and then we'll be
back at it on january 4th
so that will be our break
um yeah people asking if the uh
membership numbers are still rough yeah
i'm not gonna lie i know that they're
you know
in the interest of a lot of people do
this thing where you always have to hype
everything as if everything's just the
best and everything's perfect
i've been up front that the last three
weeks have been
a disaster for us in terms of
memberships we and it's because of
what's going on financially and end of
the year and a lot of things happening
at once oh the tyranny response team is
in the room in case anybody's uh
concerned
the tyranny response team is here in
case there's any tyranny
but the truth is the last three weeks
every day
25 to 50 people are canceling
memberships and that's a lot for us
for a membership program our size every
day to lose 25 or 50 people it's not
good
so uh i get what's going on people email
me they say david i lost my job david i
got my hours cut david i need to buy a
gift
for the holiday for my kid like i
totally get it uh but that's why we are
now completely blowing out i mean these
are discounts that certainly will not be
legal under the next administration
we're offering 70 percent off which
makes memberships like a dollar eighty a
month is it's
not a lot of money if you have a buck or
two to throw our way
uh please do sign up at joinpacman.com
we estimate about point seven percent
of our audience supports in some way and
that's fine
um the show is for everybody we i'm
perfectly happy
if we could get to even one percent of
our audience supporting we would be good
uh but you can go to joinpakman.com i
promise you
with average computer skills it takes
under a minute to sign up
and your name will pop up on my screen
and i will thank you and the bar will
fill up
and we will open phone lines and it'll
just be great it'll just be great for
for everybody um let's see
any ques people saying that the oh i
know everybody's the code is
fresh start i know people like to joke
it's fresh
shart it's not it's just fresh start all
one word all lower case
and the code it works very very strongly
i promise you the code works
okay honestly what will you do if from
some one in a million
chance trump who i hate pulls it off and
is our next president
be honest i would be extremely concerned
for the future of the country if trump
were able to pull that off
i just don't see any way that he's going
to do it
a judge tells me to keep appearing on
fox news wars are one one battle at a
time yeah the last time i
i was supposed to be on fox news i
showed up and they said oh didn't
anybody call you we cancelled the
segment
i said no nobody called me um and
they've they said oh
let us know how much you paid for the
uber and will reimburse you
it's not even worth the time it's just
you know don't don't waste my time
that's the point
and i've never been invited back
destiny is going on tim poole's podcast
tomorrow that should be about a barrel
of laughs
uh we're waiting yeah we are waiting for
a rudy giuliani
at this point in time i want to say
thanks to spudnik
for gifting five subs on twitch very
much appreciate that
and actually with the addition of those
subs
we are now at uh that's plus five which
puts us at twelve
and i also want to say thank you to
cameron mccabe signed up at
joinpackman.com
dylan lieberman cole smith
nicole zanowski sam
brody matthew garcia as well as
hugh aaron ambo which is seven
and that puts us at 19. if anybody's
just joining us
the tyranny response team is in the room
this gentleman here as you can see
uh he's part of the tyranny response
team
so fear not there will be no tyranny at
this hearing
because this guy is here and it looks
like he's got
i guess it's maybe a mini tripod in his
back
pocket or a taser i don't know uh
so that is that no car garage says what
would it take for you to post a drum
cover oh i
i want to record some stuff soon i
actually i mentioned on stream yesterday
i got my
focusrite scarlett for being able to
record
my electronic drums my plan is to add
some uh drum tracks to some of the
original songs that have been created
for the show
so i'm more or less ready for that and
we'll be we'll be doing that very very
soon
matt says i hope they have beach towels
for rudy's face today yeah i think rudy
probably switched to a different hair
dye i would be shocked if rudy's face
melts again today i
don't think it's gonna happen uh
let's see what else is going on
yeah this is there's an aspect of this
event that's just sad
uh oh good we have two different two
different shots
that's good i always we want to get all
the angles there
um are masks not required indoors in
michigan
yeah i continue to wonder i don't know i
i have no idea
well mask optional i guess at this event
denver
wants to know if we can get a dumps
related coupon code
yeah i would consider doing i mean
listen i would i would establish
something and then maybe
make the make a coupon code like massive
dump 45
and it could be like a 45 off coupon i
think that
that could be interesting to people just
an idea
shout out from brooklyn broski always
here to support thanks mario
appreciate that we should be just
minutes from the start
of this event uh oh wow a bunch of
people just grabbed memberships
holy [ __ ] the membership page is on fire
wow hold on a second is that are these
numbers accurate let me look at this
so we had about a second
54 and 9 55 and 9
that's 40 wow 46
46 people just signed up on the website
that's insane
that puts us at 65. uh well we may get
phone lines opened after all that's
actually nuts that's a huge
dump of memberships all at once and hold
on 63 that's another eight
i don't think we've ever actually
accumulated memberships at this speed
that's that's bonkers
if people are asking if this is a real
hearing listen there's a guy with a
tyranny response team shirt that should
tell you everything you need to know
about whether this is a real hearing or
not um
okay and also a big thank you to the
five additional twitch subscribers
at twitch.tv slash david pakman we uh
we're we're going to be having a very
big um
sort of meeting i guess we would call it
over the next couple of weeks with the
full david pakman show team
about uh the 2021 objectives
and i i have two big platform goals for
i don't know if people care about this
stuff but we actually do you know think
about these things
two big goals for 2021 from the
standpoint of platforms one
is we have heard rumors that igtv
will be launching a sort of similar
monetization program to facebook and
youtube
so we are looking to expand
significantly on igtv a lot of people
i'm not i'm not doing a trump thing when
i say this a lot of people really don't
know this
but we actually have a nice presence on
instagram
75 000 followers and our clips often get
20 30 40 000 views on instagram so we
want to grow on igtv next year
and twitch we want to get certainly to
the hundred thousand
subscribers and continue building on
twitch november was our best month ever
from the standpoint of twitch
and so twitch is going to be twitch is
going to be a big part of 2021 that's
for sure
um and of course me getting a show on
newsmax
and oan absolutely absolutely
no doubt about it the dude says why is
it the dems need to work to bring us
together when the republicans were
willing to let this go on there's no way
to work with these insane people right
you're completely correct you are
absolutely and completely correct
uh why is it up to joe biden to unify
everybody
um when i mean
joe but trump hasn't even accepted that
he lost why should the guy who trump
doesn't even acknowledge is replacing
him
now all of a sudden be responsible for
division versus unity it's ridiculous
now that being said joe biden picking
near its hand into his cabinet is a
disaster
and i did a um i did a segment about
that
today on the show and it was very very
uh
i think it was a very very important
segment
uh we just got 23 more sign ups
at uh joinpakman.com putting us at 101
so we will be opening phone lines we
will be opening phone lines
later on we are still standing by here
for rudy giuliani
and it looks like they're banging a
gavel here
hold on a second three uh
democrat clerks to hear their ideas on
how we can improve our laws moving
forward
we've issued subpoenas to our secretary
of state
you probably know that you know millions
and millions of
uh these mailings went out to people uh
you know unsolicited absentee ballot
applications and i've got calls and
emails from people
who say that this person died
this person moved out of school but yet
they got these applications and so we
took a pretty much unprecedented step
to issue subpoenas in order to get to
the bottom of how this list was created
why why you know why did they send this
so we can look at that and we can
improve moving forward
so that's been a lot of the role of this
committee
you know citizens have serious concerns
about the election in michigan
they've expressed that concern to myself
and other legislators
we've received thousands of phone calls
and emails
elections must be trustworthy and
accurate that includes access and
transparency for observers
correct tabulations and proper checks to
ensure votes are legally cast
uh citizens become frustrated and demand
answers when a large number of precinct
tabulations
don't recognize reconcile or when
election observers for one party
feel they were treated unfairly or when
an independent audit is not performed
is it just me or the lights pulsating
you guys see that and we have a
responsibility as legislators
to ensure trust in voting results mr
giuliani will be coming before our
committee today
he's expressed concerns with how
michigan conducted its elections
and he's president trump's personal
attorney this hearing allows the people
of michigan
to go straight to mr giuliani to
evaluate evidence presented by him
and get answers that that were let's
maybe switch over here
to go straight to mr giuliani to
evaluate
evidence presented by him and get
answers that
that we're seeking oh there will be
evidence we'll also be able to
talk to people who have just brought him
a sandwich i guess
uh with alleged voter fraud in our state
and we want to hear their stories
we want people to listen to those and an
opportunity to ask questions
and to learn more about those things and
then ultimately we can make a decision
about whether it's
true fraud or not but we have to have
these discussions
when certifying the election results
michigan's board of canvassers
is made up of two democrats and two
republicans they unanimously ask this
legislature to look into issues that
have arisen
it could be fraudulent fraud you guys
know that right
the board of canvassers in a bipartisan
vote earlier
requested the secretary of state demand
processes are better followed in detroit
we are fulfilling the board's request by
holding this hearing
and we will request the secretary of
state improve election processes when
problems are found
so i hope today's hearing will be
constructive
as we examine our state's election
system and work to reach i think it will
be illuminating for sure
well strongly that our democracy depends
on discussions like the one we're about
to have today
discussion with that uh i'd like to
welcome up uh mr giuliani
and uh jenna ellis oh my god ellison is
for
president trump yeah wherever uh that's
right there's one there
this is gonna be a [ __ ] show guys mr
chairman mr chairman
mr chairman mr chairman yes thank you mr
chairman hold on
do you have a point of order yes i do mr
point of order uh i would like to ask mr
giuliani to please stand
and raise your right hand oh he's going
to try to swear him in sworn before this
committee always trying to swear him in
mr chairman out of order mr chairman it
is i have a point of order yes i do
beautiful i mean it gets to the heart of
this these are meaningless the right
before this committee as a
representative to swear any witness
before this committee
to uphold the law that is my right
i appeal the rule of the chair and i'd
like to ask the committee to please
take a vote on this ruling because my
right as a representative
beautiful anybody before this who is
this guy is truthful
and we have the right as members to
swear anybody all right
then let's call the role court of order
mr chairman
point of order mr chairman a motion to
swear a witness in requires a
vote of this committee no it does not
all right we're gonna yeah all right
we're gonna go at ease
this should be interesting
i mean listen rudy will lie either way
don't get me wrong
this is very interesting so if you're
just joining us uh one member of this
committee tried to just swear in rudy
giuliani and notably
they're never sworn in during these
things these things are meaningless
and the guy running the committee said
no all right so you call the role on the
motion which is to
appeal the ruling of the chair okay now
they're going to vote
no representatives riley webber
no ask johnson no mcfadden no
schroeder c.a johnson yes
samuel yes
all right so with that uh mr giuliani
please proceed
with your testimony testimony and jenna
ellis as well uh we want to hear you and
then
we'll call up witnesses after that thank
you all right here we go
so his mic is off apparently
mr chairman and members of the committee
to my understanding that i'm here in my
capacity as an attorney
not as a witness if you want to
question me as a witness that's a
different matter but also i'm the
attorney for the president
ethically i don't know what that would
mean if you turn
turn me into a witness yeah we're you're
here to testify
no one i mean no one's under oath we're
just this is we know
any committee hearing uh sir where we're
just taking testimony from members of
the public
let me talk about what happened here in
the election it's my understanding
from appearing before congress many
times is when i appear in the role as a
lawyer i'm not
under oath when i appear as a witness i
am under that's important to him
he doesn't want to be under oath
attorney for someone
and it's a case involving then it would
be unethical for me to be a witness but
yeah and sir here in michigan we don't
administer all
to people who testify it's almost
unprecedented
uh in this legislation we don't give a
[ __ ] what you say
out of order i'm sorry uh
i'm gonna be very brief because i have
uh a number of witnesses
and the whole purpose of asking for this
hearing is because for
four weeks five weeks six weeks all
we've heard is that there are
unsubstantiated
allegations of fraud for it would be
before
unfounded allegations of fraud then it
became
unsubstantiated allegations of fraud
then it became
allegations of fraud but not big enough
to overturn an election
and then it became allegations of fraud
that really couldn't be completely
investigated between now and the
election
but are going to require substantial
investigation
after the inauguration so it's changed a
great deal but in that period of time no
one's bothered to look at the evidence
no one's bothered to listen to the
witnesses
i'm not a witness right i didn't witness
any of this
everything i'm presenting to you i'm
presenting with a lawyer
these are the words of other people and
in your case in the state of michigan
do you think jenna ellis's smirk is
because she thinks what rudy's doing is
great or because she's embarrassed to
even be participating
first fraud on what i would consider
i would also consider myself an expert
on prosecuting fraud
i would consider a massive amount of
evidence what i'm holding in my hand
are affidavits gish gallop by paper
sworn under oath
they have the power of evidence because
they're sworn under oath
these are these are the things on which
you bring indictments
uh and they allege massive
cheating cheating particularly on the
part of the democrat party of
detroit to the extent of
easily five six seven hundred thousand
illegal votes calculated many different
ways
courts have heard that they don't buy it
this is an analysis of a
the voting machine that you used in
much of the state i believe much of the
state not all
dominion uh broke down in antrim county
that alerted people to take a look at it
and lo and behold it became a tremendous
surprise to the people of america
did you want this closer i'm sorry
it was a very big surprise to me that
our votes
are sent out of the united states it's
also a big surprise to me that our votes
are counted by a
foreign company
and it's even a bigger surprise to me
that if you do the slightest bit
of due diligence you will find out that
this company has been in trouble many
many times
thank you go shopping in the state of
texas please say nicholas
name was thrown out of chicago in its
infancy had ties with
hugo chavez venezuela
conducted fraudulent elections in two
south american countries there it is
and have been disqualified in several
other countries and states
it appears as if whoever your elections
officials are
selected this without the slightest bit
of even googling the company where if
you did you would find out
that it's considered to be the most
insecure
voting machine uh
available to us and has resulted in
enormous
enormously terrible problems i would
like to put into the record a letter
written by my congresswoman many years
ago
carolyn maloney who pointed out all of
the problems with
this company a really old letter i'd
also
put in the record letters from elizabeth
warren
and somebody else that i can't remember
right now
but another united states senator yeah i
have no idea what you were doing
with this company and one of the things
i would suggest is
you take a good i'd like to put in a
letter from bozo the clown who believes
these machines were used at the clown of
the year
ceremony and that they are solely
responsible for him coming in third
place
we have preliminary data on how it can
be invaded we would need to examine
the rest of the machines and if we did
we could probably tell you
to some degree of certainty exactly how
many votes were changed
the formula by which they were changed
and if they were directed
overseas because there are some
indications that the vote was being sent
to frankfurt germany
or to barcelona to a company called
cycle
that's a brief overview but i think i
would rather start because this
woman i would just ask the indulgence of
the committee
this woman miss jacob is a very very
fine woman
she's never testified before
she is exceedingly concerned
for many reasons yeah and um
everybody could just be courteous and
questioning i would really appreciate it
all right thank you i'd like to call
jesse jacob
does he already get to call people just
to be clear i didn't say this before
the way we're going to run this format
my goal is to be done by nine
uh that's about three hours we might go
a few minutes over since
we're not going that long guys don't
worry goal
we're going to allow each witness to
come up and at that point
will allow members of the committee to
ask a question the question has to be
jermaine to
the topic this is about the michigan
elections okay
i'll allow one question per member no
follow-ups
one question okay that's how we're gonna
do it
for each um for each witness and that
and you know that's because of the
shenanigans i was gonna allow a little
leeway
but i'm not now all right we're gonna do
one question per witness
i was going to let actual questioning
happen until someone talked about
swearing in rudy giuliani
and then lastly at the end mr giuliani
will take those questions that's how
we're going to do it
so i understand jesse jacobs is first
could i have jenna say a word or two yes
of course why don't you go ahead
thank you mr chairman and uh thank you
to the committee and i appreciate your
calling this session mr chairman and
that we have members that are both
democrats and republicans here
but you're all here in your capacity as
legislators and this is not
a political question this is a legal one
when you have
what you will see before you as
substantial evidence
of fraud and corruption in an election
it's your
obligation under the united states
constitution
to not allow the corruption
to continue right under article 2
section 1.2
the state legislators are the entity
that our founders specifically vested
with the authority
to ensure against a corrupt popular vote
if it's a legal question it should be in
court and they lost 40 times in court
so they're here be asking you to take
action on this you've already heard
from a number of witnesses and
and other other people and evidence over
the past
day and a half i would ask you all
to put aside your party affiliation
and look openly and honestly at these
witnesses and this evidence
because here we're all americans and our
founders specifically provided
this tool the state legislature to be
able to
combat the fact that this is even
happening is a global laughing stock i
he
you know every time i cover this i'll
get like two emails from people saying
david
you're not taking the evidence seriously
enough have you guys listened to the
so-called evidence
yesterday a woman complained for 40
minutes that she didn't like how she was
treated
when she was working as a poll worker
and didn't like that some of the poll
workers during their breaks
were on their phones i mean it's like
you know the courts have heard it guys
it's
it's just absolutely crazy legislators
very very seriously the law is on your
side
because the u s constitution is on your
side
and we would be happy to answer any
questions about that at the end of this
proceeding
but thank you very much for your time
and attention today
yeah thank you and there will be
questions about that i assure you
um are we ready uh for for miss jacobs
all right please miss jacobs see what
this is about guys welcome to the house
oversight committee
and uh you just when you sit down you
uh you push the red button there you
don't have to swear and turn on the
microphone and uh
and you can speak and just to be clear
um we're you know if you speak we're not
when you're done we'll allow one
question per member but we're not
we're not going to interrupt you so i
just want everyone to be cognizant of
the fact our goal is to be done
you know a little after 9. so
welcome and thank you for coming here
today to tell your story what a joke
here we go with miss jacob as her
husband
your full name is uh sonny jacob
and your full name is jesse jacob and
jesse are you
you're a resident of detroit yes i am
and
you were born in india is that correct
yes i am you came to the u.s in 1985
that's true and you and your husband
became united states citizens
yes in 1995. and how many children do
you have jesse
three children it's funny how the
legislature
legislator said the questions must be
germaine to the voter fraud
and rudy's asking family history here
how many kids do you have
the older one she said she's my oldest
daughter she's practicing
we're getting we're on jobs of the
children but the legislators have to ask
jermaine questions can can you imagine
what's going on here guys
2014 yes
he's doing his fellowship in child and
adolescent psychiatry
at dallas southwestern
university how are the kids employment
employment details relevant to whether
joe biden didn't really win michigan you
understand right
so let's get right to it oh on september
you've been an employee
of the city of detroit for many many
years is that correct
that is true how approximately how long
since 1986. and by the way i hate to
keep interrupting but it's not like
we're missing anything that important
i thought she was giving testimony
rather than a q a
with i just don't i don't understand
this election
duties were you not that is true and you
were assigned to the
third floor of the election department
the fourth floor
the fourth floor fourth floor election
department at west grand boulevard
location and what were you told you were
you were supposed to do
the first day basically we were all um
it's about
let me see how many people about 40 to
60 people on that floor
we were first time first they were you
know giving all kinds of instructions
how this
training is going to be and then in the
afternoon so it sounds like we're not
even on election day we're just on
training period
received to the headquarters that is the
mail for
application for absentee ballot request
so basically that's what we were doing
the whole week first week
starting from september 8th uh the so
we're in september right
nine to four pm so the in their group
was working from nine to four
opening the mails sorting out the mails
and we were asked to uh sort out
according to the counting board 134
counting boards
so there are 134 counting
boxes like i said this is funny is this
is this funny or just sad i can't tell
the applications that you you have you
have
uh opened did there come a time miss
jacob
uh in about the third week of september
when you were asked to change date
so about uh the uh i think that around
september 28th
or 22nd yeah i would say 22nd third week
of september we were um we were kind of
started
packing you know making the pack ballot
packages to be sent to different
citizens
and what we do is we will do for
different counting boards 50 58 pack
you know 50 application will be there so
you you will be making
packages of 50 ballots and
on the floor um they will let you know
what they
need to be people are pointing out that
in a court of law this would be
considered the most leading series of
questions
and none of it would be even remotely
allowed by a judge you guys are
completely correct i mean but remember
these people aren't even under oath
whenever you prepare that package the
ballot package is
always either three days
back date three days you know not not
the same day
always days before that date so starting
on
the 20th of september 22nd
yes 22nd of september yes for some days
thereafter
each day you will give it a different
date yes
in order to back date yeah yes
the application yes yes
and it was a different date each day
sometimes you use the same date
you know maybe consecutive days maybe
you will use the same date
but it was different but it was never it
was never the correct day
it never be the same day the day you are
preparing the package
in other words it was a false statement
yeah it was it was a
date prior to that date that you are
preparing the
who told you to do that who was the
supervisor on the floor that day was it
one supervisor or more than one
supervisor who told you to back date
it every day
there were more than one supervisor not
just one
uh more than one so i
i would say one to three supervisors
and how long how how long did you have
that position
until you you left that position after a
short while
yes can you tell us how long you held
that position yeah i worked at the
fourth floor of the
election department october 2nd that's a
friday
um september 30th i was sent for
training
for the qef trainings of september 30th
and october 1st
i was a training then october 2nd was my
last day working at the election
headquarters
and on from october 5th onwards i was
asked to work as a processor at one of
the satellite
out of twenty three are you guys getting
this first i was
sent to soon we're gonna get to the
evidence at lasher
and sixth mile then i was
asked to go to community recreation
center
at broadbright drive near downtown did
you say commandeer
october 12th um well up
now up until the time you left yes
were other how many co-workers did you
have
when you were back dating the documents
you mean at the election headquarters
at the original place that you worked
okay they
after i think about around september
15th
or so they started second shift
until then it was only from nine two
understand how
so so like it's so it's hard to even put
into words
how crazy this all is the
this is before so this is before
legislators this is not before a court
first and foremost the election's been
certified
um these people have not been sworn in
and you have
a partisan attorney who works for trump
asking leading questions to an
individual
it i it's hard to imagine less
valuable i i can't even call it
testimony because it's
it's really not it's almost like a
scripted partisan show
package that will be entered to qef as
the
ballot mailing date and that's
that's what it is the and then the law
requires doesn't
you correct me because you know it much
better than i do yeah that within 24
hours
if you're receiving the application you
have to
respond is that correct yeah for the
state of michigan's
official manual you are required to
issue a ballot
within 24 hours of
uplink you know the request the
application request that's that's what i
read
in the michigan officials manual uh the
chapter six that's what it is written
so i don't know when i was preparing the
package i even when i was preparing the
package
or in the third week of september i even
saw
applications from june july august
so and what happened to the june july
and august applications
were they dated differently you know the
application you know the
the citizens applications you know the
data this happens on every one of these
where rudy starts to get confused about
what the claims even are and and like
he looks increasingly confused by what's
even being alleged
this happens with almost every one of
these so-called witnesses
which you estimated was about 10 days oh
and people asking why rudy isn't melting
see
how his hair is gray it seems that he
didn't use the spray dye today
yeah from september 26 second till
i would say till september 30th yeah
about 10 days
i mean i was there till october 2nd and
you estimated uh
when we went over this about 10 000 a
day
yeah anywhere between 10 000 to 15
um yeah sometimes we we will we will be
able to
complete i even remember 14 000 packages
sometimes is 12 000 so
so it's 14 000 packages times 50 ballots
each is that are those the numbers she's
saying that she was handling before we
leave this
would your supervisor say this to all of
you publicly
in other words he would say today the
date we're going to use
is this day whatever yes yeah nice
announcements
you had the phony date of the day yeah
that's the announcement they will make
yes on the floor yes
then on october's what was then you were
transferred
and you went for training yeah on
september 30th from 9 00
to 11 30 p.m a.m then also on october
1st
those were the two days i was sent for
training at wayne county community
college
from 9 to 11 30 morning session then
afternoon you will come back to the
election headquarters what do you
what do you remember of your training it
was a sunny day what were you told
during the training
it was not good it's not good no well
how wasn't it good
i mean first of all when when i was at
the wayne county community
it's about i would say around
20 to 25 people there are two groups so
i wasn't with the second group
the first group training was from
september 29
28 and 20. imagine rudy saying this is
the wrong witness these questions were
for a different witness jenna what the
hell's going on
about i would say around 20-25 people in
each group
but what i found out when i went there i
tried to
log into one of the laptop it was not
working then i tried another one it was
not working the laptops weren't working
so
so we had problems with the laptops i
couldn't even log into the system
one of them was reportedly running
windows 3.1 listen you know just listen
you don't need a laptop
okay so basically we were just some
i would say at least out of 20 25.
now you have a tape recording of this
don't you that you don't want to share
because you don't want the person
who said this hurt is that correct
no so what i did was since i i didn't
have a laptop i didn't have nothing in
front of me
i asked the instructor can i record your
lecture you know because i have to be
from october 5th i have to be
by myself i have to work as a processor
so i want to learn something so i asked
the instructor can i record your lecture
she said sure you can you can record so
with her permission i
recorded the lecture
so when we listened to it last night
did the instructor from the city of
detroit tell you it doesn't matter if
the address is wrong
or the birth date is missing or there
are no names
you must try and find a birth date
and if the signatures look different
find
something about them that's the same no
application
should be rejected is that the sum and
substance of what
that either she or he that's a she
is that what the female told you the
natural that's what basically you know
you have to do everything to to make
sure
you know that water um you know
at the end that water should get a
ballot and vote
so even if the address was wrong
sometimes the when the voters walk in uh
i don't know guys they just uh
give you the house number and the street
name
but you have different ways to you know
you can search the water in different
ways you can locate the water
sometimes you are lucky you know you
will be able to find
everything for that water then you can
process the ballot but not that
that's not that won't be the case for
everybody and suppose you can't find
everything for that person
what do you do then the instructors
sometimes tell you
you should set aside that application
and we will send that application back
to the
election headquarters let them take care
of it
you did that what happened to it i don't
know what what happened after that
that's not her job it was it was sent
and also i was sent
i i was also instructed with regard to
how to verify the signatures
you have to do everything so that the
signatures
you know you have to match it this will
never be done by nine people during the
time that you worked there
should be about a month yes except for
you
did you ever see any other application
rejected
as deficient no didn't you see people
that came up to you
that you rejected didn't she just say
that there were cases where they would
send the applications back
and then she said when she was asked and
what happened she didn't say
well it never happened she said i don't
know what happened
and now now she says i never saw one
rejected well but hold wait what
fifth that's the first day the early
voting started
thanks hannah reloaded for the raid
appreciate that
october 12th
daily i would say the first week we had
like about eight
nine waters all day from
nine till six then second week maybe
about 15 but uh the
third week and the last week of october
we had more
and i remember two or two or three times
um yeah i had to reject
uh i think in two or three occasions to
reject the ballot and they were so angry
and they were so you know angry and they
will
sometimes you know get uh call you all
kinds of name
oh you are saying i cannot vote you
don't count my ballot
and things like that and i will say i'm
so sorry you know i i cannot do you know
i mean
then i will ask my supervisor what to do
and then supervisor will say yeah i
you know just see i don't know then you
know what i see ben feingold in the chat
saying this makes a lot of sense yeah
i'm understanding none of this and it
has nothing to do with this woman's
accent by the way i want to make that
clear
eddie regardless of any accent i've not
understood what a single witness was
doing here
you can go go to any of that satellite
locations
miss jacob yes i don't want you to do
this if you feel uncomfortable
uh-oh but would you be comfortable
taking a mask off so that people could
hear you
more clearly oh my god are you hearing
me now not clear
can everyone hear it clearly we can hear
a phone
we can we can hear you okay rudy
demanding the mask come off even though
it's completely unnecessary
everybody's like we can hear her fine
we're there
did you observe her coaching voters to
vote for
biden in the democrat ticket is it
possible it's not that rudy can't hear
her
nothing she's saying is making an iota
of sense and rudy's thinking
it must be that her mask is making it
sound like she's saying things that
don't make sense maybe if the mask comes
off i'll know what she's talking about
for the election were other others of
the workers there
helping people to vote for biden and the
democratic ticket and even going into
the little
booth with them yeah i remember on
november 2nd
specifically that's the last day of
absentee
water you know number second 4 p.m
that's the deadline so that day we had
lots of people
coming to the center but he's probably
thinking these masks don't let you
breathe she's probably hypoxic and
making no sense
i don't i don't remember that person's
name but
he was working as a ballot runner
and he was going uh to the
polling booth and standing by
the side of the water and helping them
to complete the ballot
assisting the the voters are rudy's
notes written in sharpie or crayon
i was really concerned but i didn't say
anything
i don't know whether my supervisor saw
that she was in the room
but he was doing that did you find that
wrong on unacceptable i knew it is wrong
but i didn't
i knew it is wrong but i you know i'm
just a processor there
it's up to the supervisor you know i
didn't say anything
right and then was there a day when
three
uh people came in uh wearing black lives
matter
t-shirts whoa i think it was on november
2nd you said
hold on a second they were going to the
voting booth and helping people to vote
no what they did was um i think it was
earlier than that i don't remember the
excited date but they they
were three of them one was holding the
flag and one was wearing
uh i think all of them were wearing the
miss jacob what was the race of these
live matter or something like that
and one of them actually he want to
drop his uh he they were there to drop
off their
absentee ballot so they they walked in
and
they were dropping one one of them were
dropping
the ballot into the box so another one
one was cheering and the other one was
taking picture and things like that
that's suspicious i knew it is also not
right but
yeah i cannot do anything it wasn't
right to cheer voting sitting
on my desk why is that bad doing my
processing job that's all
now about 14 days before the election
your supervisor
who i think you told me she observed
liberals voting
and it felt very wrong meeting with her
boss
and that you should stop asking for
driver's license
or photo id yeah what she told me was
they are all registered voters you don't
need any photo id or driver's license
they can just you know come in water
let them let the people vote so
you know so basically but
as a processor i was not comfortable
doing that so myself
i was when they come to my table
i i used to ask them at very low voice
can i see your pers travis lessons
please
i used to get from all of them show me
to make
myself comfortable when i am issuing the
ballot but i was told not to
uh ask because they are all registered
waters
you asked them for driver's licenses and
photo id
yes i did and what happened i mean that
way i can
verify their signature the signature on
the driver's license
with a signature on the application and
also the signature in the qvf
so i can verify all those three and when
they are when they return the ballot to
me
i can see how they are signing if rudy
has ten pages of notes per witness it's
going to be a long night
return envelope so basically
all four locations you know in the qbf
file
on the driver's license and then the
application and on the
ballot return envelope so they are good
if
if all four of them are matched i will
receive that ballot into the qvf
i'll save it and i will place my initial
on the
valid return envelope but it number date
and again initial so
two initials i have to place on the
ballot
return envelope when i am receiving the
ballot into the qbf
so i was doing that for each and every
balance that i issued
that's what is required by the
michigan official manual
now your co-workers didn't do that and
they asked you didn't they
why do you do it and didn't you say for
my peace of mind
yeah the driver's license was that the
point when they said you don't need
driver's license
i said for my pso man i'm going to ask
anyway i'm going to get the
driver's license and i'm being told that
super jew was just a name that scrolled
by along the bottom of the screen i
don't know what that is i assume that
these are donors to to this stream i
don't know
they've got a hell of a lot of donors by
the way enter the water's name
correctly into the system and also to
to verify the signature and also of
course the photo id
did you also have to check signatures
yes yes you do
that's the first thing you do before you
even start processing the ballot
and weren't you weren't you
on several occasions didn't you turn
people down
yeah very angry at you and then they
went to one of your co-workers
and your co-workers accepted them one
time i remember
one young gentleman this is a very
strange hearing i i don't know how else
to even describe it
the his signature at cuvier fire rudy's
notes really look to be written in
sharpie or some kind of black
crayon um the signature in the file and
he said oh that's
that's that's not i don't sign like that
that's what that was from
10 years ago i don't sign anymore i
don't sign like that anymore
and i said sorry i cannot do anything
you know i
but i think at that mo point um i think
he walked out
even though the supervisor she was there
i don't think supervisor did anything i
think she
the gentleman walked out
so they're coming so she's she's just
yeah she's essentially describing
that black lives matter t-shirts made
her
think something wrong was going on and
she decided to
ask for id to feel good despite the fact
that that was not the protocol that she
was told to apply
deal with it and then how were you told
to deal with it
what i do is when the water walk into
the
the room the the front the person at the
front desk
they will bring the um driver's license
that is
that is the first two weeks of october
this is their best witness
they will bring the application and the
first thing i will do is i will
enter the water and you will do a voter
search then then the system will tell
you whether city already mailed the
absentee ballot to them or not whether
it
is
whether there is an active ballot in the
qef system
it sounds like it sounds like she's
participating in voter suppression like
i'm more concerned by how she's
preventing people from voting
than anything she's described so far
come to you they they said i never
requested a ballot
i never received any ballot i never
requested for the ballot
can i vote now i'm here i want to vote
now
i said of course i mean i can spoil the
ballot
um then you can i can uh
issue another ballot and you can vote
so i have done that many times um
but for the look at rudy's face that was
i was instructed to do like that but
by but for the michigan officials manual
you are required to get a affidavit from
that person
and you know stating that you know um i
couldn't find my ballot or
um i didn't receive the ba or whatever i
don't know
but that but enough you'd have it need
to be submitted
but we were just asking them to fill
that form
that's what we were doing but they
didn't have to bring that
that ballot back to you that is saying
first battle
to them they didn't have to bring it
back
i remember during that one month period
maybe
i got like some of them voluntarily
bring
i got maybe around five or ten of them
total
that's all but you are not required to
bring it back
just fill out a form then you will get
another i'm going to be honest
i don't know if she's talking about
applications or ballots i i genuinely
have no idea
then i will receive that ballot into the
system
so now the other people that worked in
your in your center
did they require the original ballot
or an affidavit before they issued
a new ballot no no none of us were
trained to do that
none of them did that no and that's what
the law requires correct
for the michigan's official manual yes
if you lost your ballot or you you have
a damaged ballot
yeah and that's so somebody doesn't vote
twice
right yeah i don't know what happened
with the first ballot
this is where you have to accept the
whole point right is there evidence
anyone voted about 32
32 500 of those ballots you estimate
were issued
without spoiling the original ballot
i mean the period of time you were there
i mean you know if you audit the file
with the city of detroit election
department
from the qef you can find out how many
ballots were
spoiled how many ballots were rejected
how many ballots were deleted all those
things you can
find from the so the excel number
i i mean i mean it's about right i mean
i can speak to my
center where i work um the common year
recreation
center location
i i would say how many ballots i spoiled
the first two weeks there were lots of
you know um third week of october
i would say around um
i would say around hundred dollars maybe
i spoiled
i can i may be wrong but i don't know
exact number but
all right guys well listen we're gonna
take a little bit of a step away from
this i did promise to open some phone
lines and i think we're going to do that
i don't know that this is going to be
any different for the next
three hours so as promised we are going
to be going
uh exclusively over to twitch
for the live calls so we will pinch off
the facebook and youtube streams if
you're watching on youtube
hit that subscribe button so that you're
notified of future streams
but come on over to twitch at twitch.tv
david pakman i will open the phone lines
i want to hear from you and i'm going to
be doing that right now as promised
because we did hit this goal
of 100 new members so come on over
twitch.tv
david pakman i'm going to see you in
just mere seconds
mere seconds okay let's see you over
there